una ráfaga de morteros golpea kabul la
capital de afganistán durante la mañana
del sábado el caos se apoderó de las
calles del centro de la ciudad tras la
explosión de una docena de cohetes que
dejan al menos ocho muertos y decenas de
heridos eran aproximadamente las nueve
la mañana cuando un mortero golpeó el
área de sartén frente al centro
comercial màgic y la panadería slice
hiriendo a uno de los empleados quien
fue llevado al hospital el atentado ha
dejado pérdidas financieras hoy años
sabios locales de la zona los múltiples
impactos provocaron cuantiosos daños
materiales en varias áreas residenciales
afganistán está asumido de nuevo en una
ola de violencia con diferentes grupos
terroristas entre los que se encuentra
una filial del estado islámico operando
en el territorio
estábamos saliendo de nuestra casa
cuando ocurrió una explosión y dos de
mis hermanas y mi madre fueron heridas
las hemos llevado al hospital
los talibanes que continúan dialogando
una parte estancada emitieron una rápida
oración negando cualquier
responsabilidad los insurgentes
prometieron no atacar zonas urbanas en
virtud del acuerdo de retirada de eeuu
pero el portavoz del ministerio del
interior afgano ocupa el grupo de la
reciente escalada de violencia los
terroristas talibanes se enfrentan a la
nación el evento terrorista de hoy es la
enemistad evidente de los terroristas
con el pueblo un nuevo ataque que se
produce cuando el secretario de estado
de eeuu mike pompeo se reunirá en doha
con representantes del gobierno afgano y
los talibanes en medio de las
conversaciones de paz para un país
desgastado por una guerra endémica